This is my favorite thing about content, why it's so important, guys,
and listen to me carefully, nobody is willing to do it.
Nobody is willing to do it. And that is exactly why we are going to do it.
And that is how we are going to win. It's by doing the things that everyone else
is not willing to do, is how you win the game.
You want to know a really good way to make a lot of money?
A guaranteed way, go find a business or a service or a job that nobody wants to do
and go do it. And figure out how to do it in a way that's quick and that is fairly reasonably
priced and you will become very wealthy. Because it's the jobs that nobody wants to do
where there are heaps of money sitting. This is one of those jobs.
Content, writing content is one of those jobs.